So now we need to add work flow actions and what work flow actions are, are
simply the things that are going to you know,
fire as soon as that criteria is met.
>> Can we add an email?
>> Yeah, let's do that.
>> So this is going to email our technician.
>> It's going to to immediately email them
for records created and they have an email.
>> So this thing can be email technician.
>> Yep.
>> Email template, so what's that for?
>> So, in Salesforce you can create e-mail templates that use merge fields,
similar to what we've already seen in our formulas.
>> Okay.
>> And so it auto-populates with fields off of
that object, so you can say something like, Dear
>> Bob.
>> Technician's name. Yeah.
>> Okay. That's pretty cool. and, have you kindly made this template already?
>> I have.
>> Thank you, Sam.
>> Yeah. So pick the Maintenance Notification, not the solution.
>> Okay. And recipient Type. What's this all about?
>> So we can dynamically
assign who the recipient is based off of, you know, maybe they're
part of a queue and we wanted to go to a maintenance queue.
>> Mm-hm. Or maybe they have a specific role. And so,
we're trying to dynamically determine who should receive it by role.
>> Okay.
>> But in this case, we could use the related user.
Which is the mobile technician that we have associated with the record.
>> So, we'll use technician.
>> Yeah.
>> And then from current user's email sounds fine to me.
>> And Save?
>> Sounds good.